now these aren't your average EQ as soon
as look at you African crocodiles here
these are crocodiles spinning a feeding
frenzy tearing apart an antelope they're
busy to say the least with a big job to
do enter a hippo our hippo inexplicably
starts to lick the bodies of the feeding
crocodiles scientists haven't figured
out why yet but hippos seem to enjoy
hanging with these bloodthirsty killers
as they shred their victim and gorge on
its flesh talk about insolence why do
the Crocs put up with us well first of
all the hippos are no threat they're
vegetarians secondly the hippos are more
powerful than the Crocs so the Crocs
carry on as if the hippos aren't even
there and if you think this is bullying
here's a baby hippo wading into a bevy
of crocodiles you know it must be
genetic the baby hippo immediately
starts gnawing on the spines of the
Crocs back now this has got to be
annoying but well what are they gonna do
answer nothing you want to know how
hippos feel about the so called danger
of getting too close to a crocodile yeah
yeah I guess that about sums it up